it's really fun i think one of the most
fun parts is like looking at the symbols
in like hiragana and katakana and trying
to think of ways to remember them oh
right like remembering the shapes
right yeah yeah one of my favorites is
oh god i know you told me some of them
was like you're stretching it dude the
hiragana for
wah
most people say it looks like a wasp but
for me it looks like wario's fat dunphy
the strength of mnemonics is like the
stronger or the more profound the image
yeah the easier it is to remember and
like now that you said that i would
never ever gonna unscene i'm gonna
see wario's fat dump truck ass man we've
used like this even though that's a
stretch by the way i want to say it's
not little eyewear i can see that more
than the wasp yeah the wasp
i don't know if that was true the one
for
a like the yeah yeah katakana is just i
like the letter r yeah oh like a
stretched out eye yeah all right so so
like this thing was like this this thing
i i don't know if it was the same one we
used it was like it's an engineering eye
beam so think of engineering
yeah yeah yeah that works for you
but i'm just like this is i feel like
we're really twisting like what we can
do here i'm like e for engineering
that's actually how i remember it that's
how i
i remember excited i'm an engineer yeah
me too but i'm like i'm like i feel like
this is not a good way to do it thus i'm
remembering because i remember that
there was the one dumb
one yeah
but the point is you remember right
that's all that matters literally the
fact you brought it up in conversation
because you remember it yeah
it worked but i i'm i'm annoyed that it
works because it's dumb like warrior's
fat dumpy oh also the character for roll
yeah looks like a roblox head
no it doesn't
it's a squishy it's literally a square
katakana it could oh my god
i had this exact same moment i think
everybody learns japanese has this
moment where emily saw
like so you know right yeah there's a
kanji for like gucci yeah like mouth
it's like kind of the same as it all
yeah yeah emily was like i know how to
read this one it's the draw and i'm like
[Music]
emily it's not wrong
and you're like
but what
but it's
i'm like you're gonna hate this emily
but also care it's also a kanji as well
that comes up a lot well you weren't
doing you were talking about air like
the engineering air right that's also
kanji
because like uh like some of the place
names they'll often have the old ones
and it's really annoying yeah because
it's not even remotely similar yeah
[ __ ] kanji dude also sometimes i oh you
know what really threw me off when i was
trying to learn katakana
a lot of some katakana symbols
look really similar to characters in
korean oh no i've already been
conditioned
really which ones because my head is so
different paul looks like a one
[Music]
yeah
oh coffee's here our coffee's here what
looks like i i was wondering like why
you ran off and of course it was because
the coffee came oh i didn't even realize
it right now
i was like
in this conversation it was like we were
mid podcasting connor's just like
like really desperately needed the
toilet because they're like
conversations what the [ __ ] no he just
sees
this is going to be in the episode he's
just not even here i'm being caffeinated
right now i want to hear it
yeah but yeah like wall like yeah yeah
yeah that's like the korean character
for the
oh yeah they're remotely similar so i've
had to like extra train my brain same
for the character for uh food yeah yeah
it looks like the good oh yeah
so like every time i see it i'm like
good and i'm like no no it's full so i
have to like really stretch my brain
when i see those characters when i see
foot i have to imagine a comic panel of
like a cute character laughing like
all right that's how i remember do you
know the poo like the like the symbol
yeah pu
like for in in qatar like
it's food with a circle it looks like a
man running right
you just you see this right what
pooh looks like a man running dumb
i'm corner until connor said that i was
like what the [ __ ] are you talking about
and then i saw it and my mind was blown
because i never learned he's not gonna
like that doesn't like just a man
you just know the language
i said that's the scene
[Music]
oh my god it does
it literally looks like the olympics for
like the the running like what they
would use because 100 meter dash
i didn't see that until you pointed that
out as well i literally can't unsee it
like i every time i look at it it's like
first it's the man running second it's
poo
no but like it's funny you say that
because like i remember like back in uh
college i spent like a week to challenge
myself to see if i could learn hangul
because like it's easy apparently it's
one of the easiest writing systems like
in the world right because it's only
like 20 yeah something letters right so
yeah but like i used i used the opposite
where like i saw ger and i was like oh
that's just foo
is it is it that similar it's literally
the same oh it's the same but it's but
in in hungary
i wonder how it is like learning
mandarin from like learning mandarin
kanji man oh dude like i remember like
in in high school in uni when we had
like our japanese like curricular like
place was right next to where mine was
yeah so like there was like all my
friends who were studying japanese and
uni yeah would come out being like [ __ ]
man we're on kanji right now and all the
[ __ ] chinese students just like belly
laughing being like
elementary [ __ ]
i like this years ago
it's like i [ __ ] hate them all
meanwhile we're just like one of these
like hieroglyphs
yeah
this is where we're at now joe this is
this
you can barely laugh now i can barely
laugh
like elementary
my other favorite one that i actually
taught daidus was the katakana for for
ka yeah looks like the side profile of
samurai jack and he uses a katana every
time he sees it he's like he's like
what's this oh samurai jack car
these are getting longer and longer like
you're like
why is for uh when you go to the store
and you go wow there's no dishes left
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah i just learned from like i guess
kind of class but also
having really awkward conversations
where i get things wrong a lot oh that's
the best way to learn it is i feel like
getting drunk and talking to japanese
people is like the best way yeah yeah
yeah because if there's one thing
japanese people love to do is teach
japanese to yeah like they love it like
if you're in like a bar setting and you
say something a little bit is wrong then
they'll be like uh no no no it's this is
how you say it and like they want to see
you improve right yeah whereas like i
feel you don't really get that in a lot
of like english-speaking countries i
feel mm-hmm i don't [ __ ] teach
english to someone yeah right no yeah
yeah
people like english people get annoyed
when someone goes exactly like they'll
be like so why is the was there k and
knight
it looks [ __ ] badass you think a
knight would look good without a k come
on that's the reason why it's the cool
one it has the edge yeah man that's like
the k is a cool letter
yeah but right it's like i feel that's
just like so interesting how there's
just like that dichotomy right yeah well
i think it's just like because it's the
same with tai as well where if we see
someone trying to actively learn the
language
uh that we speak it's just like we're
proud of that now we're proud that
that's like oh you're taking the time
for us yeah yeah we're proud of that
yeah same with walsh actually people if
people are interested i'll tell them
yeah
if you're interested i'm like let's get
good
yeah i'm glad you're having fun because
like
mnemonics like some of the funnest parts
of just like creating a story like
whenever like you remember a word
because like i still use it whenever i
like try to remember like a new japanese
word or something
um like because you can use it to
remember
um the katakana and the kanji as well
but you can also create stories or like
different things when you're just
remembering words
like for like for example like cheap is
like yasui right and i always remember
like it's so i whenever how i learned
that is i just remember just like i
imagine sydney like picking up like a
really cheap person going yeah
and now i'm just i'm never gonna forget
like that's cheap as yasui because i
just remember yes
no no [ __ ] wonder scientists have no
idea how the [ __ ] brain is yeah
what the [ __ ] is going on
well now i'm gonna remember that that's
so good wait what's expensive
yeah
so you think